le chemin dans boivent les révélations
des femmes autochtones dans le reportage
de l'émission enquête au sujet de
l'agression qu'elle aurait subis de la
part de policiers ont déclenché une
véritable tempête qui a fait plus de 30
ans contre avec les communautés
autochtones ont fait beaucoup de choses
qui sont fait pour rapprocher les
cultures diminuer lé racisme et jour au
lendemain c'est un peu comme si tout ce
qu'on a fait dans les 30 dernières
années avaient été balayés on a
également mis en place au niveau de
notre résout une cellule de crise mais
depuis des choses ont changé à val d'or
la sûreté du québec a commencé à
installer des caméras dans ces autos
patrouilles québec a nommé aujourd'hui
même deux enquêteurs autochtone qui
participeront à lenquête du service de
police de la ville de montréal sur les
allégations contre les policiers de
val-d'or l'embauché de travailleurs
sociaux sera aussi confirmer d'ici peu
pour soutenir les policiers dans leurs
interventions avec les autochtones
donc ici sur la tête les cuisines peu
après la diffusion du reportage québec a
débloqué 6,1 millions de dollars pour
lancer plusieurs projets pilotés par le
centre d'amitié autochtone de val d'or
parmi eux la maison chez willy un centre
de jour pour itinérants qui à val d'or
sont majoritairement des autochtones
qu'est ce que l'élève l'annnonce du
gouvernement a permis b c
c'est vraiment d'accélérer le
les réunions l'ouverture mais il ya un
certain malaise ici plusieurs seulement
pourquoi d'autres organismes
communautaires qui offrent aussi des
services aux autochtones n'ont rien reçu
de québec résolution
la question est si délicate que personne
n'a voulu la commenter à la caméra le
maire de val-d'or affirme cependant
qu'il s'agit de l'une de ses prochaines
priorités notamment pour soutenir
l'organisme la piaule qui viennent en
aide aux personnes défavorisées et
itinérante
il ya aussi une volonté que si ces
partis de val d'or il ya des solutions
qui vont émaner d'ici moussy val d'or
retrouve donc son calme après la crise
et attend avec une certaine appréhension
la prochaine étape soit le dépôt du
rapport d' enquête du spvm au cours des
prochains mois ici francis labbé
radio-canada vador